you know what's better than seeing your
favorite character destroy someone
seeing your favorite character overpower
someone using sheer brain power alone
well sometimes but anyway I'm sure that
there's almost no one who doesn't like
watching characters outsmart each other
and win with high IQ moves with that in
mind we did our research and got a whole
bunch of moments lined up from kaguya
and miuki waging mental Warfare over an
umbrella to a bunch of kids from the
promised Neverland trying to escape
their slaughter house here's a list of
the top 20 1,000 IQ moments in anime to
scratch that mental
[Music]
itch starting off this list we have a
moment from the Vinland Saga when
escaladed his ship over land well
technically a bunch of his men carried
their ships over land but it was a
strategic masterclass by him since it
took the Enemy by surprise and led to
him capturing the French Fortress the
entire plan was exceptionally unorthodox
as who in their right mind chooses to
carry ships to raid a fort ascal ad
that's who to add insult to injury after
raiding the Fortress ascal ad and his
crew run off with the treasure leaving
their employer in the dust definitely
one of the smartest moves from one of
the best strategists around that's when
you know that Vikings are the real Chads
of history in
[Music]
animee next up is a fight from one piece
that deserves a spot on this list Luffy
fills himself with water to fight
crocodile it's especially impressive
because it's from one of the
conventionally dumbest characters in the
series at this moment in time we and the
straw hats aren't aware of what hary was
and that meant that there weren't many
ways you could beat a loia type devil
fruit user and boy was crocodile's Sans
San fruit overpowered Luffy's top moment
was when he used his rber body to fill
himself up with water he used that water
to make crocodile tangible allowing
Luffy to hurt him with physical attacks
Luffy used his Ingenuity and battle IQ
to take down a warlord of the sea which
was quite an impressive
[Music]
[Applause]
feat come
again kickstarting his way onto a list
we have a moment from Blue lock where
isagi outsmarts Ren now you may remember
in Samurai Jack where Jack and Aku had a
face off and they outsmarted each other
by saying I knew that you knew that I
knew well something similar happens in
this situation isagi knows that Ren is
extremely Adept at reading him and knows
exactly what he intends to do with that
fact in mind isagi turns the tables on
Ren knowing precisely what he would do
and countering it in Epic fashion the
outcome is isagi scoring a massively
difficult goal on Rin Ren ioshi is known
to be one of the most intelligent
players in blue lock and watching him
get scored on just shows how great of a
move isagi played when he outsmarted
him
moving up the list we have jaro tricking
Enya from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
Stardust Crusaders how do you fight
something that doesn't have a tangible
form it's hard to punch something like
that so how is jaro supposed to be Anya
stand in one of the best IQ moments
that's how to beat someone who's a
literal Mist you do what jaro thought of
you inhale them oh my God while star
Platinum couldn't physically harm
Justice due to its mislike form it
managed to inhale the entirety causing
Ena to suffocate and leaving her
entirely at the mercy of jaro possibly
one of the easiest ways jaro has used
his cunning to end a
[Music]
fight
blasting his way into our top 20 we have
Sid versus Olivia from Eminence in
Shadow now fans of the series already
know that Sid is extremely overpowered
and normally destroys anything that
comes in his way but what happens when
he has brains along with his Brawn well
basically what happened to Olivia in the
fight many copies of Olivier show up and
finally the real Olivia gives Sid a
really bad wound unfortunately for
Olivia though Sid was waiting for the
real one to hurt him so he could grab
Olivia's neck outright bite her and
remove the copies after taking care of
her copies Sid uses his epically
destructive move I am Atomic to destroy
the entire Sanctuary defeating both
Olivier and Nelson at the same time it
was an outstanding move as he brought
the opponent into a false sense of
security before taking them out entirely
that bite was just menacing
[Music]
too
we're at the halfway point now so if
you're enjoying this video don't forget
to drop a like And subscribe to the
channel if you haven't done so already
thank
[Music]
you making its way into the list is a
moment from Fate Zero where git suu
outsmart kth sometimes these moments are
awesome because they end with a really
smart character being humiliated and
other times they end with a really smart
character being outright murdered it may
be tasteless when the latter happens but
there's no taking away from the fact
that it was an astoundingly high IQ move
by git zugu rather than having Lan fight
saber in an honorable match git zugu
chooses to pressure GTH into forcing Lan
to take his own life after that's done
kiritsugu proceeds to assassinate both
kth himself and his wife it was utterly
brutal but nonetheless a very smart way
to defeat lansa without putting saber at
[Music]
[Applause]
risk
a up next we have boli versus Vector
from swordart online now this fight
showed bur's will along with how quickly
he could think on his feet to defeat an
incredibly powerful opponent boli isn't
Weak by any means but Vector was just so
strong that the entire fight seemed very
one-sided boli got his arm chomped off
and was basically at death's door when
he got an opening to attack Bodi took it
in a really smart move Bodi OB to Target
vector's past slashing it to defeat the
villain he did lose his life in the
process but defeating such an incredible
enemy required that sort of sacrifice
the overall scene was great and the
animation was amazing too which it's
kind of like a cherry on top an amazing
fight scene and some high IQ moments
what more could you
[Applause]
[Music]
need
for making its way we have the Great
Escape From The Promised Netherland now
the series has showcased its protagonist
as being amongst the smartest kids
around and they've proven that time and
time again what's especially impressive
is that they uncover the reality of the
orphanage they're in and the monsters
that they're being raised for it's
incredibly dark but makes way for
showcasing the cunning of these kids
Emma was an utter Mastermind for this
and succeeded in escaping with most of
her it's especially impressive because a
family consisted of even younger
children so it was a Monumental feat
when you ended up outsmarting the
exceptionally genius adults and
basically escaping from a prison meant
to raise you for
[Applause]
[Music]
Slaughter moving on we have another
thousand IQ moment from the anime freen
freen versus Aura now this moment came
up when freen fought against the great
demon and Sage of Destruction Aura now
Aura is a very strong character with the
ability to basically control anyone to
do anything if her opponent happens to
have Mana reserves less than her own but
free rent was one step ahead having used
aa's power against her in all normal
cases free rent would have lost if she
had to face that entire Army but Aura
ended up using a spell of obedience fre
R's incredible moment was that she had
suppressed her Mana for the entirety
this time and all her life for that
matter if Aura knew that fre Ren had
such a high Mana Reserve she would never
have used her spell of obedience but
since fre Ren only revealed her true
Mana levels after the spell was cast
Aura had no choice but to be completely
under her control which ended with her
losing her life at her own hands freen
was just cold and
[Applause]
merciless
punching into the next spot is karma
versus grip from assassination classroom
it's always fun watching a guy who looks
weak beat an opponent who seems much
stronger on paper especially if the
tactic used is pretty devious during the
first half of the match Karma avoided
all of grip's attacks during the second
half he fought in hand-to-hand combat in
the third part he pretended to be
paralyzed and ended up dousing grip with
the paralysis spray he used used first
on Karma now the moment showed how
brilliant Karma was at turning the
situation in his favor and displayed his
fighting sense as a well-trained
assassin just goes to show though
doesn't it bronze aren't
[Music]
everything rumbling his way onto the
list is Aaron manipulating his father
from Attack on Titan
[Applause]
now Attack on Titan has been known for
its tragic events especially how Aaron's
parents ended up but the real kicker of
this situation is that Aon was in fact
the one who orchestrated everything that
happened on Paradise literally
everything Aaron used his ability to
influence the past made his father do
everything to get the founding Titan
into his grasp including manipulating
him into feeding himself to eron when he
was younger and into killing the entire
Reese family it's such a high IQ moment
that is confusing even when you try to
explain it showcasing how far ahead
eron's plans were just so he could get
his
[Music]
way
before the top three of this list we
have the second entry from the big three
of Shonen the way Shikamaru defeats
hedan in Naruto now Shikamaru is known
as one of the smartest characters in
Naruto and he certainly lives up to that
even while fighting a guy who's
supposedly Immortal Shikamaru cleverly
used gagu zo's blood instead of his own
causing kakuzu to lose one of his hearts
and outsmart Hedon how do you defeat an
immortal guy well well you blow him up
and bury him 6 fet under of course what
else Not only was this a thousand IQ
moment but it was such satisfying
revenge for Shikamaru and the fans
because of how he done killed Asuma so
that's why in the future Shikamaru
becomes Naruto's right-hand
[Applause]
[Music]
man entering the the top three of this
list we have Isen humiliating the
captains of Soul Society from Bleach now
eizen was an incredibly calculating
villain Eisen had been manipulating
everyone for quite a while making them
run around in circles until he finally
went face to face with a whole bunch of
captains you'd think that you'd be able
to overpower one former Captain who
doesn't even have a bank gue but no
Eisen was multiple steps ahead even then
during the start of the fight Eisen
pretended to be on the losing end only
to show that he was in no danger at all
eisen's ability to manipulate their
senses and control the situation made
the captains feel utterly powerless and
incapable of challenging him what's
cooler is that Isen looked like all of
this took him zero effort brains and
Brawn are a powerful combination
especially if it's
[Music]
Isen next up we have Lou tricking the
entire world from code gas just like how
Aaron manipulated the events of his
country we have Louch who manipulated
most of the world shown to always be
incredibly smart Louch was proven to be
a spectacular strategist he literally
overthrew the strongest Empire in the
world by participating and then
controlling an entire Rebellion through
a series of calculated moves and
political Maneuvers he manipulated
public opinion and staged elaborate
events all with the aim of positioning
himself as a common enemy to unite the
world against this intricate plan
allowed him to maintain control behind
the scenes while appearing as a
sacrificial figure for the greater good
ultimately deceiving the entire world he
literally became a villain after
dominating everything just so the world
would unite and his sister could live in
peace what a mad
[Music]
lad
at the top of the list we have light
killing L from Death Note now death
note's a show where two of the smartest
people in the world have a clash of
ideals and play cat and mouse the show
has such a high number of high IQ
moments since both the characters have
insanely High intellect during the
entire span of the series we see L try
to figure out who the killer Gira is
while light tries to find a way to kill
l so that he gets off his back so of
course the highest IQ moment in this
exceptionally long battle of wits was
going to be when one character won
against the other unfortunately for El
though he was on the losing end as
lights plans bear fruit in which he even
tricked
himself he literally made himself forget
his memories all to get close to El and
finally land that fatal blow on him it
was truly a spectacular feat and one
that deserves the highest spot on this
list
[Music]
and with that we're wrapping up this
list of the top 20,000 IQ moments in
anime considering that there are
countless smart characters all around
we're sure that we probably miss many
that would be at the top of your list so
do make sure you let us know in the
comments about those if you enjoyed this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
if you want more of this high IQ content
see you next time